warum erkennt man denn die
wahlergebnisse nicht an also warum
erkennt die opposition die
wahlergebnisse nicht an warum geht man
davon aus dass die wahl manipuliert
wurde
ja es ist relativ einfach
das geschrieben von alexander
lukaschenko hat bereits vorher gesagt
dass es die wahlen gewinnen wird
lukaschenka hat bereits vorher gesagt
ich könnte ihnen sagen wir die bahn
gewählt aber warum sollte ich das tun
das wissen wir doch sowieso alle und so
ist es dann gestern auch gekommen
die angeblichen exit polls also die
nachwahlbefragungen haben 79 prozent für
lukas schenkel vorhergesagt sozusagen
die staatlichen am ende waren es jetzt
sogar 80 prozent die er bekommen haben
soll
das widerspricht allem was man
tatsächlich sieht hört und liest aus
weißrussland das ging schon sind damit
los dass am tag gesagt wurde am morgen
der wahl gesagt wurde dass 42 prozent
ihre stimme bereits abgegeben haben das
ist ein riesiger werte gab es noch nie
die also vorher im briefwahl gewählt
haben
in der tat sah es tatsächlich so aus
dass das nie dagewesene schlangen vor
allen wahllokalen standen und die
menschen haben in den schlangen offen
immer wieder ihre ihre unterstützung für
startups kaya zum ausdruck gebracht also
hatten fahnen dabei haben haben
geklatscht haben haben die zeichen
gemacht und so weiter und dann
da hat man also schon gesehen dass das
wirklich nie dagewesene gewesene machen
für die opposition stimmen würden
im ausland war es sogar so dass das ist
quasi demonstrationen waren die vor den
wahllokalen stattgefunden haben jeder
dort hatte ein bagger oder ähnliches
dabei und dann haben wir die wie gesagt
wurde eine anmoderation es gibt einige
wahllokale die ihre ergebnisse
veröffentlicht haben und überall ist zu
sehen dass braut dieser noch mit
absoluter mehrheit gewonnen hat also mit
riesigem abstand im schlechtesten fall
nur 55 prozent für sie im besten fall 85
herr lukaschenko ist jeweils also in
einigen kleinen wahllokal hat er wohl um
die 30% gekriegt in den meisten nur etwa
zehn prozent
in berlin zum beispiel haben die
menschen im konsulat gewährt dort haben
wir die offiziellen wahlergebnisse dir
ausgegeben wurden auch dort hart drauf
dieser oscar 91 prozent der stimmen der
weißrussen in berlin bekommen und herr
lukas schenkel hat fünf prozent bekommen
es ist also völlig klar das ist ein
erdrutschsieg war für die opposition der
wie es aussieht von der wahlkommission
einfach umgedreht wurde und was meinst
du wird die opposition jetzt machen wird
sie das ergebnis anfechten
also wir haben wir schon gehört von dem
lager von eine frau die von oskar ja
dass man das ergebnis dass man sich als
sieger sieht der wahl
wir haben gehört dass heute ergebnisse
veröffentlicht werden sollen die auf
grundlage von 20 prozent der wahllokale
zustande gekommen sind die opposition
hat also nach eigenen angaben aus 20
prozent der wahllokale die ergebnisse
bekommen
sozusagen war gerade die schon vorher
gesagt haben wir sind nicht mehr bereit
und menschen also lehrer usw
staatsbedienstete die vorhergesagt haben
sie nicht mehr bereit hier falsche
ergebnisse zu liefern
und man möchte das veröffentlichen die
schätzung ist etwa dass man 70 prozent
der stimmen gewonnen hat das ist eine
sehr vorsichtige schätzung
das könnte auch wesentlich mehr sein
dazu hat man heute zu weiteren große
protesten aufgerufen
die sollen im laufe des tages
stattfinden und ich denke man wird also
weiter versuchen auf der straße jetzt
sozusagen das recht durchzusetzen und
die gewonnene wahl auch in die tat
umzusetzen
ja wir sehen auch gerade immer wieder
die bilder wie lange glaubst du denn
kann sich alexander lukaschenko noch
halten angesichts dieser proteste dort
das ist schwer zu sagen also ich will
ganz spannend ist es dass die haben wir
in der ukraine im dezember oder im
herbst winter 2013/2014 etwas ähnliches
erlebt nämlich dass dort ein
massenproteste war
präsident janukowitsch hat damals am
allerletzten tag seiner präsidentschaft
bevor er muss man geflohen ist versucht
die armee einzusetzen vorher hat er es
mit spezial und halten mit polizei und
so weiter versucht
herr lukaschenko hat gestern am tag
bevor die proteste los bei um die armee
in einem beruf nach minsk und in andere
städte
man sieht also da ist eine ganz anderes
selbstverständnis der mann ist seit 1995
an der macht und hat offenbar nicht die
geringste absicht abzutreten egal was
sein volk möchte und das ist tatsächlich
beängstigend dass das also man von
vornherein die loyalen truppen die
spezialtruppen aus den kasernen in die
großen städte holt und sich dann
offenbar auf das vorbereitet hat was am
abend geräumt ist nämlich einer
oppositions sieg und große demonstration
das haben wir gestern gesehen dass seine
erste flugzeug einem flugzeug von ihnen
in der türkei geflogen ist auch ein 60
millionen dollar jet also der mann ist
nicht nur extrem mächtig sondern auch
extrem reich hat also das land ausbluten
lassen und sich selber bereichert ist es
nicht klar wieder an bord ist einige
haben wir es dann schon gesagt
vielleicht er selber es ist wohl nicht
der fall er hat sich aber noch nicht
geäußert andere haben gesagt vielleicht
seine kinder vielleicht mit teil seines
vermögens insofern scheint er zumindest
auch verschiedene opposition
verschiedene optionen zu erwägen
wir wollen jetzt auch ein handy video
zeigen dort sieht man wie unerschrocken
ein demonstrant auf die polizei zugeht
was sagt dieser szene deiner meinung
nach aus was symbolisiert sie gucken
kurz rein
ja ja ja so was haben
ein einzelner mann sozusagen der nicht
nur ein flugzeug steht sondern wir sehen
wir haben verschiedene videos gestern
gesehen die menschen haben keine angst
mehr
die menschen sagen wirklich das kann
einfach nicht sein wenn wir wenn wir
wissen dass wir die wahl hoch gewonnen
haben wenn das ganze land gegen den
diktator sich gestellt hat und der der
taten weiter nach sagt ich habe gewonnen
dann ist dabei fielen offenbar ein punkt
erreicht wo sie sagen das lassen wir
nicht mehr mit uns machen und das lassen
wir auch nicht mehr mit in form von von
rhein von reingemacht ethischen
widerstand mit uns machen sondern gehen
auch auf die straße und werden auch mit
allen mitteln unser recht was wir uns
durch wahlen verdient haben jetzt
durchsetzen wollen
man hat den eindruck dass viele andere
länder dort weg schon denn seit 26
jahren ist ja lukaschenko an der macht
warum denn erst jetzt die proteste also
man muss dann die proteste gab es
tatsächlich immer wieder im jahr 2010
gab es schon nach seiner wahl damals
habe ich auch mit etwa etwa 80 prozent
gab es proteste wurden niedergeschlagen
2015 nächste wahl
die war im rahmen der ukraine krise da
war es ein bisschen spiel ist weil die
leute hatten tatsächlich die westlichen
politiker hatten andere probleme zu der
zeit und auch die gesamte region
aufgrund des krieges der dort herrschte
tatsächlich ist aber so das ist
erschreckend wenige reaktionen bisher
gibt vom deutschen außenminister
beispielsweise bei der kanzlerin
wir wissen sonst dass bei solchen lagen
sehr schnell auch mal einen tweet da ist
und sehr schnell reagiert und bisher
haben wir da überhaupt nichts gesehen
auch von der europäischen union nicht
ich denke da muss im laufe des tages
tatsächlich nur einhellige reaktion
kommen dass man eben europäischen oscar
ja dort den sieg anerkennt und dass man
nicht alle geschenke ganz klar nahe legt
dass er das
das dass er die niederlage eingestehen
muss das ist glaube ich dass andere
mindeste was die aus deutschland und die
eu jetzt machen können